the world's richest man Elon Musk
changing his mind on joining Twitter's
board of directors after becoming its
largest shareholder which frees up the
billionaire to launch a potential
outside bid for complete control of the
company musk has been critical of
Twitter for stifling free speech and has
been pitching ways to transform the
platform including a plan to turn
Twitter's headquarters into a homeless
shelter
Jesse what of all the companies that
this guy who buyed any by any
you know objective definition is
probably the greatest innovator of our
of our era why Twitter you think he
would invest his time and want to invest
these billions in well he's on Twitter
and he likes it and he doesn't like
where it's headed so if he owns it
you're not going to be able to rig
another election Herald and Spike a
negative story about a Democrat I write
that down well you don't need to you
should already know it
other than that him owning Twitter's not
really going to affect Americans on you
know day to day most Americans aren't on
Twitter and the ones that are don't
really tweet they just listen and then
they read but you can tell how annoyed
the Democrats are by how they're
reacting so hysterically to this because
Twitter is their own little club and
they get to kick people out of it and if
he gets control of the reins they're not
going to be able to have that juice
anymore and that's what threatens the
left the most losing power in any way
Harold can I respond I think that Jesse
is wrong I think I want this counter
from you right extremely wrong
it will affect America by affecting
journalists because journalists go to
Twitter for their dopamine hit right
they go there our journalists aren't
chasing stories anymore they're chasing
likes and that's what's shaped away the
shape like look what it did to CNN right
all CNN was trying to do was feed off of
what they saw from the loudest voices on
Twitter and it drove their Network into
the ground what have we always told
staff Twitter like you don't don't let
Twitter influence what you're doing or
you know you can look at it but don't
let it shape your opinions because if it
does you get more and more extreme right
what he's gonna what he can do and he
knows it it's like a patriotic Duty he's
going to go in and he's gonna uh he's
gonna like kind of detoxify journalism
in a weird way he's gonna like you know
it's drugged our media and he's gonna
take that drug and take it out he's
going to turn it upside down and what
you're going to see is journalists are
going to be like
oh my God I have to report stories now I
have to go and talk to people before I
used to just go on Twitter won't they
still be able to be hacks on Twitter
what's the difference yeah but you know
what they'll be they'll I don't know I
didn't think about it
and you you I mean I think that's an
interesting point that Greg is making
about what this does what Twitter
Twitter's impact on free speech and
Twitter's impact on journalism does he
have a point there and you think must
thought about that I don't know if you
saw last week the New York Times editor
told all of the right the journalists at
the paper get off of Twitter because
you're not chasing the stories that we
need you to chase you're chasing
everybody else's likes so I mean the New
York Times just figured that out and I
think there's less and less activity on
Twitter I find that not as informative
as it used to be in terms of kids used
to get at least to get breaking news on
there now it's just like people like
with their long opinions and all their
threads and it's just too much
um Bloomberg is reporting that there is
a day of rest for the staff of Twitter
to to cope with all of the stress hope
okay I have no time for these Twitter
kids they're the ones who figure out
what to push yeah right they don't have
the hashtag thing anymore they're the
ones figuring out trending topics that
almost always goes against conservatives
look at the headlines that they use
right so now they have the mob after
them and I have no sympathy
is it a platform for free speech judge
and how you know someone someone was
talking about I think it was Bill
Bennett last week saying he's he's
innovated in space he's Innovative with
electric cars could he be could what
must be doing now really help change how
the courts and how we jurisprudence sees
Free Speech see I believe that he can
and I think you know what was the most
fascinating to me was when he said he
had 9.2 percent of the shares and then
he was going to go on the board then the
next day he says I'm not going on the
board obviously because he doesn't want
to be controlled by the board he doesn't
want to be limited to 14.2 percent or
nine percent which he would be limited
to if you were on the board now he can
buy as many shares as he wants he's not
limited to uh you know like insider
trading or fiduciary responsibilities I
mean based upon simple things that he's
saying like turning headquarters into a
camp for the homeless I mean you know I
love everything about this guy he wants
to turn everything upside down and I
think that and he wants people to be
able to pay you with Dodge Coin I mean I
just think that he is a guy who believes
in the first amendment I think he can do
it from outside as opposed to being on
the board and I think he can be very
very effective and you know when the
Washington Post op-ed call to prevent
the wealthy from controlling the media
platform I think that probably irked him
and now he's like you know what now I'm
really going after them well Bezos
bought the Washington Post and so maybe
he thinks he needs to have a media
organization himself up next a radical
climate group encouraging criminal
activity to fight global warming I
wonder Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now